[Audience Clapping]
Ella is going into the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame next month,
and you've performed there,
- [Guest Speaker] Yeah. (woman laughing)
- Which I know. (woman chuckles)
What is your experience with that?
It's so amazing.
- Oh my gosh. The Rock and Roll Hall-
I remember when the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame,
wasn't really a place.
And then-
- What?
- Because there was no hall of fame yet,
it was just,
you were being inducted
and they were trying to build it.
- Oh
- And so I inducted Janis
Joplin and Bonnie Raitt.
But then in 90 (indistinct)
- Oh my gosh.
- I know.
- Just, that sentence alone.
(both laughing)
- but then like in 95, 94,
they had a big concert to open the hall.
- Yeah
- That was amazing.
Kelly, you would have freaked out because-
- Like who all were there?
- Everybody was there.
I remember standing in the side, you know,
they had a little stand
for people backstage.
- Yeah
- First of all,
I remember dancing with
Chrissy Hind and Sheryl Crow
- What?
- and Natalie merchant.
We were all dancing to like Al green
or something.
- What kind of dream
sequence is this, yeah?
- I know. No, it's crazy.
And then we were on the stands
with Bruce Springsteen and
John Fogerty and John Mellencamp and,
(Kelly laughing)
and we were all watching James Brown.
- What?
- So it was unbelievable.
It was unbelievable.
I even did a, a thing with,
with Bruce and Chuck Berry.
It was unbelievable.
You'll never see because
Chuck messed it up.
He's he's really weird that way.
(audience laughing)
- Wait, wait, I want to know how?
- No, because he (indistinct)
he totally, we had, um...
A ducked down in the, um..
the Stacks band playing
and they had been drinking a little bit.
(Kelly laughing)
and you know, cause it was a long day.
And they, we were playing.
And so Bruce said, Hey,
do you want to go play,
you know, rock and roll music with Chuck?
I'm like, yeah.
And so Chuck tells me and Bruce
it's in the key of G,
but he tells the band
it's in the key of B flat,
and those two don't mix.
- Oh...
- And so half the song, we're
all going, 'what's going on?'
It was really bad, but he
is notorious for doing that.
I don't know why.
(Audience laughing)
I don't know
- I kind of really love it.
- Yeah, it's all.. (mumble)
- Not if I'm on stage
- No, I was like 'oh...'
- but if I'm off stage, I'm
like someone did something
(guest speaker laughing)
That's amazing.